اللي مكتوب له عمر حيعيش السلطات
الكولومبيه عثرت على اربعه اطفال لهم
اربعين يوم ضايعين في غابات الامازون بدون
ماء او اكل الغابات هذه بتعتبر موطن
لحيوانات مفترسه وتعابين وحشرات قاتله
وزواحف وكمان مع قله الجار المخدرات ومخبا
لهم النجاه من ضياع اربعين يوم وسط كل هذا
يعتبر معجزه لكن تخيلوا ان القصه مو بس
كده الاربع اطفال هدول اصلا ضاعوا في
الغابه من بعد ما تحطمت طيارتهم في الاول
من مايو وفي رحله داخليه بطياره صغيره
طاحت الطياره وتوفت امهم اللي كانت معهم
والطيار وشخص اخر بالغ قريب لهم كمان كان
معهم على الطياره يعني وجلسه السلطات 18
يوم تدور على حطام الطياره ولما لقيته جثث
الثلاث البالغين وما لقيت الاولاد وبدات
عمليات البحث الاطفال للعلم اكبرهم بنت
عمرها 13 سنه واصغرهم 11 شهر يعني رضيع
وعلى فكره كمل سنه وهم ضايعين في الغابه
وفي طفل ثالث كمان عمره تسع سنوات وواحد
اربعه سنوات امس واخيرا لقيوهم بعد اربعين
يوم طبعا وجوههم شاحبه اجسادهم نحيله لكن
عايشين على بعد خمسه كيلو مترات من موقع
الحادث ونقلوا للمستشفى
بطائرات للعاصمه
[موسيقى]
البحث عن الاولاد بدا بكل الطرق طيارات
واقمار صناعيه يعني كل الطرق الممكنه
وكانت الطائرات كمان بترمي اكل وشرب
واوراق ومنشورات فيها خرائط للخروج من
الغابات الكثيفه على امل انه الاولاد
يلاقوها وامان العثور عليهم زادت لما
لقيوا احذيه وحفاضات وفواكه ماكول نصها
بالاضافه لاثار اقدامهم وزادت اعمال
العثور عليهم اكثر واكثر لمن لقيت فرق
الانقاذ بيوت او ملاجئ يعني كده مصنوعه من
نباتات الغابه كانوا بيعملوها الاطفال
يمكن علشان يناموا او يرتاحوا فيها يعني
الاطفال عثر عليهم على بعد خمسه كيلو متر
خمسه كيلو مترات خلينا نقول من موقع
الحطام لكن عمليه البحث غطت مسافه اكثر من
2600 كيلو متر وهذه كانت حاله جدودهم
وقرايبهم لما سمعوا خبر انهم لقيومهم
وجريو الناس على المستشفى شايلين لهم اكل
العالم كله تابع اخبار الاخوان الاربعه
وقصه نجاتهم ومن التفاصيل المؤثره جدا في
القصه حديث جده الاولاد عن انها كانت
متاكده من ان الشقيقه الكبرى وطبيعتها
المحاربه رح تنقذها هي واخواتها لانها
دائما كانت بتساعد امهم فيهم القصه شغلت
العالم وحتى الرئاسه من اول يوم كانت
متدخله فيها وشفنا الرئيس بعد ما اعلن على
تويتر انقاذ الاطفال شفنا هو وزوجته
بيزوروا الاطفال في مستشفى في العاصمه
بوغوتا ووصفهم بانهم حيدخلوا التاريخ
معنى من القاهره المغامر ورائد الاعمال
عمر سمره اهلا فيك معنا عمر طبعا يعني انت
زي ما يقولوا شايف حصتك الكبيره من هذا
النوع من
الاخبار وسمع كثير من هذه القصص وبعضها
حتى عشت مغامرات انت شخصيا يعني هل شفت
شيء بهذا الغرابه
اهلا بك يا ساره الاول
بصراحه القصه لما عرفت عنها فعلا افحمتني
يعني لان احنا بنتكلم على قدره البقاء في
مكان زي كده للكبار تعتبر شبه معجزه للمده
دي من غير اي ادوات من غير اي احتياطات
انها يعملوها اطفال وفي في حد منهم سن
الرضيع ده يعني حاجه ممكن اتخيلها يعني
بتاخد بالها منهم عمرها 13 سنه يعني انت
بتقول انه احتماليه البقاء بالنسبه
للبالغين كانت حتكون صعبه طب كيف قدروا هم
كصغار كيف ممكن نفسر انهم قدروا يتعايشوا
مع الموقف
خلينا نقول حاجه اول حاجه طبعا ممكن الناس
تستغرب هي دي اخدتهم 18 يوم عشان يلاقوا
الطياره نفسها
احنا بنتكلم دلوقتي على الامازون انا كنت
اخر مره رحت الامازون كتير اخر مره كان في
شهر واحد اللي فات خلينا بنتكلم على غابه
كثيفه جدا ممكن تكون في غطاء شجر شبه يعني
كامل فطبعا الطيارات ودي تبقى اسرع طريقه
ان الواحد يعمل مسح لمنطقه كبيره جدا من
فوق انت مش بطريقته اي تفاصيل
فلما لما الاقوا الاطفال في الاخر خالص
يلاقوهم في مكان مفتوح شويه قدروا يوصلوا
له بعد بعد يعني عده كيلومترات او هو على
بعد التلات ساعات ماشيه من مكان الحادث
لكن طبعا هم يعني مشيوا على الاقدام
كيلومترات كثيره جدا عشان يوصلوا
الحاجه التانيه يمكن اللي استوقفتني في
الموضوع
هي ازاي ان هم قدروا ان هم
يعني يفكروا هم طبعا لما لما لقوهم كانوا
على حاله يرثى لها وكانوا في صحتهم مش
كويسه وكمان ده طبيعي جدا
فكره ان واحد يلاقي يقدر ان هو يجيب ميه
من الادغال ويقدر ان هو يعرف يتعرف على
ايه الحاجات اللي ممكن ان هو ياكلها ما
ياكلهاش في حاجات سامه اعتقد
الاهالي الاطفال دول هم من السكان
الاصليين للامازون ودي يمكن نقطه
استوقفتني شويه لان
احنا كان ناس متمدنه
افتقدنا كتير قوي من يمكن
التقنيات او المواهبه للبقاء دي حاجه
مهارات البقاء كده الاساسيه لو كنا في
مكان رو او طبيعي جدا يعني
مش عارف لو الاهل علموهم ده او الجدود
علموهم ده ولكن هم اكيد البنت الكبيره
اكيد شافت ده في
القبيله فعشيره بتاعتها في جدتها في جدها
وقدرت ان هي تاخد حاجات من ده لما واحد
يكون مولود وعايش في مناخ معين او بيئه
معينه بيقدر ان هو يستشف كتير قوي يتعلم
كتير قوي بعيدا عن قرايه الكتب وبعيدا ان
حد يشرح له هو نفسه بيعيش الموضوع ده
فاعتقد اكبر
عنصر يعني خلاهم يقدروا ان هم يعدوا في
الكلام ده احنا بنتكلم في 40 يوم فده ده
كتير جدا ايوه
نفس كمان الموضوع انه الناس لما بنحطوا في
هذه المواقف بتكون عندهم غريزه البقاء زي
ما بيسموها او بيكون عندهم مثلا ادرينالين
اكثر للتعايش مع الموقف ولمحاربه الموقف
يعني عايز اقول لك حاجه انا انا وعمر نور
زميلي لما يعني حصل الحادثه بينا في
المحيط الاطلنطي والمركب اتقلبت في عاصفه
شديده جدا
يعني كانت رحله البقاء او التحدي كان لمده
13 ساعه هو طبعا كان في مناخ صعب جدا
وعاصفه في وسط المحيط ولكن الواحد بيعدي
في مرحله
يعني فقدان الامل وبيعدي كمان في مرحله ان
هو مش عاوز ياخد اجراء هو مستني ان حد يجي
ينقذه وانا متخيل في في الطبيعي في المطلق
للاطفال عامه لو بنفكر في اطفالنا او
اطفال غيرنا فطبيعي جدا ان هم يفضلوا في
مكانهم مستنيين حد يجي ينقذهم بس هم ممكن
يكونوا عملوا ده الفتره صغيره بس هما
عرفوا بعد شويه ان هم لازم يتحركوا لازم
يبتدوا ان هم يشوفوا حلول لان ممكن المكان
اللي هم فيه ما كانش امن ممكن يكون عشان
يلاقوا ميه عشان يلاقوا اكل الطاروا ان هم
يتحركم انا عارف ان هم كانوا بيستخدموا
اشياء من
[موسيقى]
الطياره الحاجات موجوده في الطياره صحيح
ايه طب
عمر احنا واحده فاجانا فيها بعد هذا
الموضوع انه لقينا فيه خبراء اللي هم يعني
مختصين في
النجاه او البقاء يعني سرفايفل اكسبرس
اسمهم موجودين كده ما كنا نعرف يعني
هو فعلا يتضرس يعني ممكن حد يروح او يروح
كورس سيرفايفل طبعا بيتقسم الى سرفايفل في
الجبال سرفايفل في المحيط اللي احنا
اضطرينا ناخد
لما عملنا المحيط طبعا بخبرتي في الجبال
قبل كده كنت عملت
واحد بيتمرن ان هو ازاي ان هو ينقذ نفسه
لو اتحط في موقف لكن كمان ازاي ان هو ينقذ
الغير لو اتحط في موقف وطبعا في ناس
عدت في التجارب دي اكتر من مره في قصه
يمكن واحنا واحنا صغيرين قصه يعني يمكن
الهامتنا كتير جدا اللي هي القصه بتاعه
اللي هي الفريق الراكبي الارجنتيني اللي
حصل
في جبال الانديز وقعد برده اسابيع
واضطر ان هم يعني في منهم في منهم توفوا
اضطروا الاحياء اضطروا ان هم ياكلوا يعني
كانت قصه
رهيبه جدا
والناس اللي هم
عدوا في التجربه دول لسه لسه عايشينه يعني
في متقدمين في السنه لسه عايشينه بيطلعوا
يتكلموا على القصه دي برده يعني ملهمه جدا
انت مرات بهذا النوع من التجارب الكلاسيز
هذه اللي اخذتها هل فادتك يعني وقت لما
تيجي حزت المشكله المصيبه يعني بتكون
مفيده
لو اكون امن جدا فانا بقول ان هي بتساعد
الواحد عشره عشرين في الميه لان مثلا اللي
احنا كنا بنعمله في جزء منه ان احنا ازاي
ان احنا نطلع القارب المنطقي وازاي ندخل
جواه وازاي كلام من ده كنا بنعمل ده في
حمام سباحه لان طبعا ان انت تعملي يعني
تقسيم
يعني ان يكون في عاصفه ده هيكلف الافات
وعشرات الالاف من الدولارات فالواحد دايما
بيتعلم السكيل نفسها بس مش بيعرف ان هو
يعمل الموضوع كله فما فيش عامل تجربه
نفسها فانا واحد بيكون متمرن على ده لازم
ان هو يعمل الكورس وكلام من ده لكن في
النهايه هو لازم يدخل في
المكان نفسه ويعيش تجارب حياتيه في ايام
اسابيع لحد ما يبقى عنده الموضوع ده لما
يحصل ما بيكونش بيفكر فيه ولكن بيحصل
بالفطره عمر البنت اكبر البنت اللي هي
يعني حمت اخوانها ويعني مرت فيهم يعني في
التجربه هذه كلها اسمها كانوا بيقولوا
انها هي محاربه على اسم المحاربه او على
اسم محاربه معنى اسمها وهكذا انت كمان
مسمي بنتك على اسم برضو كده محاربه ايضا
ده مزبوط فعلا بنتي اسمها تيلا بس هو اسم
على كرتون انا كنت بتفرج عليه وانا صغير
الشخصيه نفسها بتاعه
محاربه وفي نفس الوقت عندها
قدره الشفاء للغير
يتحط في موقف زي كده لكن بعتقد ان قدره
الانسان على البقاء والمحاربه حاجه مهمه
جدا في في كل يمكن في كل جيل ولكن في
العالم بتاعنا في التحديات اللي احنا
بنواجهها ان الانسان يكون عنده من
المثابره
وقوه نفس ان هو يقدر يعدي في اي حاجه تتحط
قدامك والكل واحد يعني ياخد من اسمه نصيب
ان شاء الله يعني كمان فنحن بنشكرك على
هذه المداخله وهذه التوضيحات كان معنا من
القاهره المغامر ور ائد الاعمال عمر سمره
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]